(relaxing harp music)
(harp becoming dissonant)
- [Natalie] Myra!
That was amazing.
- Oh, thank you.
- It was just so... Wow!
- Well, thanks for coming.
- Yeah
- It's really nice to see you
- Great to see you.
- [Grandpa] My boy.
My boy.
- Hi, Grandpa, you came.
- How could I not show up
at my favorite
grandson's performance?
And I have to say,
the performance tonight
was interesting.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
Anyway, look, I've
got a meeting.
Got to go.
But before I go, just
give Grandad a kiss.
(Myra sighs heavily)
- Myra.
On the lips, Myra.
- Grandpa, we talked about this.
- I know, come on.
(suspenseful music)
- Is that it?
Is that all I get?
(music intensifies)
You must be Natalie.
- Yeah, hi.
- Nice to meet you.
(car door slams)
- So, what was that
with you and your Grandpa?
- What?
Did you notice something weird?
- A little, yeah. Mm-hmm.
- I guess I have
this little fear
that maybe I'm
attracted to my Grandpa.
My grandfather made all
of his grandchildren
kiss him on the mouth.
I think it's because he
wasn't a good communicator
and that's how he
expressed love.
So, when I was 14, he made
me kiss him on the mouth,
and it moved.
Why did my cock move
when he kissed me?
Is it because maybe
I'm attracted to him?
And I can't stop
thinking about it?
It got super hard.
It's never been that
hard ever since.
Why did my cock move?
- You were going
through puberty.
- I can't stop picturing things.
- What kind of things?
- Like licking his balls.
- Uggh.
- I just see two giant balls
and I wanna put em in my mouth.
- [Natalie] You want to?
- More than anything.
(bird chirps)
(breathing heavily)
- No.
- I said stop.
- God, what?
- Oh, I'm sorry.
I can't stop picturing my
grandfather's big cock.
What's up with you?
- Fine.
- No!
(Natalie sighs)
(phone vibrates)
- It's your Grandpa.
- Pappy?
(playful lounge music)
(diners chat softly
in background)
- [Grandpa] Come on
Myra, say something.
- What?
- Tell us a little
bit about your work.
How's your work going?
- It --
- [Grandpa] There it is.
The face to break
a thousand hearts.
- So handsome, right?
- [Grandpa] Runs in the
family, really does.
- [Grandpa] Myra?
I think he's choking.
Myra, are you okay?
Come here, come here.
Let me do it.
- Natalie!
- I don't know the Heimlich!
(Myra grunts)
(Myra groans)
(suspenseful music)
(Myra gasps)
- Grandpa!
- You okay?
Yeah, yeah, you're
okay (laughs).
(Natalie gasps)
(playful lounge music)